People see the end result, which is
a shiny red airplane. And they go,
well that's nice. You know, like
that's, that's cool. But like,
it's more to me than that's
the reflection. Everything
I had to do to turn that
growing up for me was like,
I did have energy,
but I don't have anywhere to put it.
He Sky Surfing,
we love you so much.
And he teaches us cleaning.
So like at school, um, I was put
in special Ed. They didn't like,
I just felt like nobody, nobody
believed like I was capable of anything.
It was just like being in timeout.
I would just sit there and,
okay.
Not really do a lot.
When you become like unconfident,
you don't know how to,
how to recover from that.
Oh,
I don't have a really good way
of being like other people.
Oh,
I was just bullied enough for teas
to where I thought I am weird.
I was really restless and at this school,
like the institution just does,
it wasn't speaking to me at all.
I really needed to find something
that I was passionate about.
Oh,
you found it right at the right time.
dad left in order the office and
picking you up. Don't take the bus.
And he picked me up from school that day
and there was a leak in the hangar and
we had to fix some sheet rock.
Even from the day my dad gave me that
note in school like that was the beginning
of the chain that changes your life and
you never know what it is until you look
back.
First Time I came to the
airport and saw the airplane,
I saw something I wanted to be involved
in for the rest of my life and at that
point I was like, whatever
it takes. I met Matt Gugan,
probably the most influential personality
and Matt showed me help with things that
he was working on it and I was actually
getting really interested
in. I was like, oh,
this is how it works like this and
this is how this works. I was placing,
the blocks are so long and now
coming out to this airport,
I felt like I was out of that box.
Mac put me on these floats
that need to be told apart.
So there was like a couple thousand
rivets and I just started drilling on one.
I think having somebody
believe in me sparked the EXEC.
We were working on airplanes
now you know I'm 14,
we're working on airplanes and he
is expecting me to do at your job.
He knows not going to
be perfect at the time,
but I kept trying really
hard and you recognize that
I started using my special ed hours
reading like ground school budget,
everything I didn't learn in Algebra.
Ended up learning in metal shop.
Now they have the contrast
like school doesn't care.
And then Mac and the people in the airport
like caring, like they believe in me
and I was kind of addicted to it.
I just kept coming here and
eventually they start paying me.
I knew as a freshman I was at least going
to be a pilot as it have an airplane.
I didn't know exactly I was going
to do it. Um, but this was a star
improve.
People say like if you want something,
you have to want it more than you want
to breathe. Wanting that airplane,
there was no option to quit on it
because I was identifying with that
when I was in a hunt for the Cessna
one 70 Mack had already said,
you should get a project.
My Dad called and said that his boss knew
where one was and Max is all you just,
you got to buy that one max,
like Spitz's ice tea and it's dripping
out of his like white beard. I said,
Okay Dad, you know, I guess,
I guess we're buying it.
When we found the plane, it
was green and white, somebody,
he'd carve their name into it.
So it was this old banged up fuselage
without any wings on or anything
and it was, it was a wreck,
but like it had the potential.
Yeah, it was excited. I mean I was only
15 and I know, and an airplane. Yeah,
sure it can fly, but it didn't
matter. It still still upset.
I owned an airplane and the registry,
so I own one.
When I was younger I was definitely more
impatient and wanting to get things,
wanting to do like the action and get
like get in it and get things done and
kicking.
People thought like, Oh, we
bought an airplane. He'll
get bored of it eventually.
I couldn't imagine not finishing it.
I would work like 10 hours a day and I
started building this plant up and things
were,
things were looking pretty good,
but nothing ever really goes according
to plan. A lot of help today going on,
Sam,
I just wish she knew what I even did.
Earn a hundred bucks
so that goodbye screws.
I did some construction jobs.
I dug ditches.
I worked at a refinery to pay
for the rent on the hanger.
I even spent months up in Alaska fishing
for salmon and fish like years just to
earn as much as I could.
Okay.
I was out in these storms that are telling
them to 12 foot waves, 30 knot winds.
I officially am til 11:00 AM and then
again from 3:00 PM to 11:00 PM and you
learn how to like sleep outside, like
lean against the war. I'm exhausted.
Sleep outside,
put on,
try to like channel that warm air coming
out of the manifold that like getting
hypoxia or anything
fishing taught me a lot no matter what.
When it's time to fish,
I have a question.
You don't quit
building the plane itself
wasn't the hard part of it.
Okay.
The hardest thing has been,
you know,
keeping motivated through the entire
process and like absolutely not taking no
for an answer and doing whatever
it takes to really get that done.
Uh,
I couldn't imagine not finishing it.
I could probably go over every part
and just tell you like the experiences
building, just that or what
happened to get that part.
I was laying with a learning disability,
but by 21 I became a certified mechanic.
If finish college 708 quarters early,
I'm private pilot and I
built my own airplane.
I didn't let what anybody else
thought of me dictate what I do
doubt myself. And it's not
uncommon for me to doubt myself,
but then I see how far the planes coming
and how much progress had maintenance,
and there's no way I can go back on that.
If you want something bad enough,
we truly want something bad enough,
then you have to make the sacrifices.
I could buy steak,
but I by airplane parts instead.
This is just the beginning of this.
What's next for me is to
have the experience of flying
a serp plan every state,
and that's really important to me because
I know that there's a lot more than
just country to see, and the plane
is the perfect way you do that.
[inaudible].